and we start with the panel on religion
conversion and caste moderated by Gowri
Vishwanathan um thank you all for coming
this morning this the first panel for
today and actually the only panel is on
religion and cost and in setting up this
panel we begin with the understanding
that Ambedkar Ambedkar very carefully
deliberated his conversion to Buddhism
taking 20 years to actually convert and
then lead one of the largest mass
conversions in history and he also used
those twenty years to study various
religions not only Buddhism but also
Islam Sikhism and Christianity so that
20-year period was absolutely crucial
for Ambedkar in both undertaking this
very serious scholarly study of world
religions but also to totally psych-out
they particularly the Hindu communities
who were very anxious about his threat
as they put it to convert and thereby
take large masses of people away from
the Hindu fold Ambedkar Ambedkar search
for a moral framework which we've been
talking about over the last two days and
that this this search for a moral
framework to resist cost oppression
released refused any possibility of
non-religious alternatives which some of
his more atheistic marxist supporters
were urging urging him to think about
and embed girl remained entirely
skeptical of the promises of
emancipatory legislation if it was a
purely formal act without any particular
moral impact so in this panel there are
three large areas that the very the four
speakers
intend to address first of all
historically in the articulation of
Dalit consciousness there is a junction
between Dalit identity and costless
identity the question that some of the
speakers will be asking is how does this
tension play out within ostensibly non
Brahminical religious communities how
moreover does the Dalit project of
conversion out of Brahminical traditions
articulate with the project of
reconstructing an indigenous past
another set of questions relates to the
act of conversion itself what are the
reasons for the Lib conversion or non
conversion to the religious tradition
that each of the speakers on this panel
studies why conversion at all when there
are other non-religious alternatives to
social and political transformation what
emancipatory possibilities are offered
by religion that are not available or at
best limited under a secular regime and
I think yesterday there were some
questions that asked this very
fundamental question about religion for
liberating purposes and then finally the
last set of questions deals with what to
what extent and in what ways do the
categories of the state and government
ality generally structure or determine
the religious landscape of Dalit India
to what extent for instance does
withholding Scheduled Caste status from
Dalit Muslims and Christians while
granting schedule + schedule caste
status to the lip-syncs since 1956 and
Buddhists since 1990 and Hindus
influence the nature of relations both
within religious communities and between
religiously different the live
communities in categorizing the units of
Indian society is the
the stage plane rule that is essentially
neo-colonial or secular progressive or
Brahminical the order that we've decided
on for today's panel I hope will emulate
Ambedkar's own very deliberate study of
various religions in this conversion
process and we've tried to achieve embed
codes own thought process by first to
this very deep speculative theoretical
interest in the very category of
religion and of course this is the the
prime question that addresses many
Ambedkar scholars you know why religion
for political transformation um and as
on Baptists develop these conceptual
frameworks for the relevance of religion
in his a political project he also
undertook deep empirical historical
studies of various religions which I
have already mentioned include
Christianity Islam and Sikhism so the
order of this panel attempts to emulate
that thought process and so therefore we
will begin with Jana our Lucius who is
an independent scholar in New Delhi and
elosha Susan he has served as the Ford
Foundation professor of Dalit studies at
the Academy of third-world Studies in
New Delhi and he's also been a visiting
professor at the University of Hyderabad
the University of Heidelberg and the
University of Delhi he has published
numerous papers and I'm not going to
mention all of them but I do want to
mention his important books which
include and nationalism without a nation
in India which was published I think in
1999 right and then he has also edited
various collections most recently I
think or maybe this is not so recent but
I thought I would mention Lakshmi naruse
religion of the modern but this which is
published in 2002
and dr. lucious has extensive experience
working with the tribals and Scheduled
Castes of Jharkhand including trade
union organization among the mining
construction forests and beauty workers
in sync Assam boom district be hard and
he has also set up and run non-formal
education centres among the whole people
and he has set up the tribal
documentation center I will introduce
the other speakers just before they
speak but the order that we will follow
is dr. Lucius first and then Raj Kumar
Hans and then Nate Roberts and finally
Massoud so Allah says would you like to
friends I appreciate this invitation to
this seminar particular I'm grateful
particularly to those who literally
labored to transport me from New Delhi
to me and I'm grateful to all of you
where long ago professor Gopal guru
wrote an essay another neglected one
where he tried to explore the academic
division of labor as theoretical
Brahmins and should rely on priests
sudra scholars are supposed to do
empirical work slave labor collect data
and so on and brahmins will sit on that
and theorize means ideologies and I have
been battling that try to say there is
been an implicit theory in all this
empirical work done by the sudras and an
attempt is to extricate that that is a
time to hear what madam has severely
said fifteen minutes so I could maybe
send maybe a telegram long telegram
what you'll make out of this you will
like to see is the first this has the
three parts first I make some historical
observations and then I try to flesh out
some larger implications theoretical or
speculative or whatever it is and then
discuss some of the questions put
forward in front of the panel by the
organizers the very first point that
should sink into our consciousnesses
that during the colonial period there
has been a pervasive percolating though
uneven mass movements by the hitherto
relegated castes and communities across
the subcontinent it was it was the
pervasive phenomena now historiography
would say yeah there were some period
there and Ambedkar there the rest were
all nationalists
no it is not itself it's a problem of
story ography not history and this has
structural implications structural
implications now m1 Sweeney was known
for a sanskritization and so on I try to
pick up something interesting from here
as suggested that it was as though they
are no longer inhabiting a present house
no this lower caste atoms
you know the images imagery is very
important breaking down the Bastille
that was not of course of that dimension
but still there was something the second
thing is what was the context in which
district place the context was sudden
and also equally pervasive authorization
of the numerous communities who came to
be later called backward and the lathe
and minorities etc came to be called so
later there's a sudden sub authorization
and corresponding coming to hegemony of
the Brahminical Brahminical both as an
ideology and also
human agency human agency of the
Brahminical now there are various ways
of describing this Brahminical middle
classes elite and all that I try all
that but then I find the most that
approximates this is just to say
Brahminical and explain that
now this Brahmanical I'm not going to
explain now the Brahminical came as the
new middle class the leading class as
Ambedkar calls to set up the new
political economy civil society etcetera
on the one hand on the other hand the
same brahmanical came and presented
itself as the Hinduism under the
colonial period the core of Hinduism the
Brahminical thing so the Hinduism notion
was not only a residual notion of - 'm
muslims and christians the rest of the
country is Hinduism descriptive
phenomena but also a prescriptive notion
that Hindu means one has to abide by
certain things and so on see the both
the areas what the the the secular as
well as the sacred had come up now this
is what has been mentioned again by
immense renewals in a I have put it in
his inimitable insensitivity to power
differentials within society
he says Varna became popular under
colonialism now this the kind of running
away smashing of the prison house by the
so called lower castes also had two
dimensions one is they were trying to
appropriate the new opportunity
structure Education Employment political
representation and so on
and simultaneously they were also
constructing new political and religious
canopies religious roofs now we are
accustomed to say that these people are
not sufficiently secularized
sufficiently rationalized that's why
they still hang on to the Phenom
a religious thing and so on on the other
hand you're going through all the
surveying all this you would find it was
a very very conscious and consistent
attempt to construct a new religious
canopy's in order to match their new
newly emerging exists tential position
in political economy and civil society
and so on the sigh of the oppressed so
audacity they were reconstructing a
religion that will express the
aspiration as well as their own
ambitions within the sacred realm itself
now obviously in keeping with the
consonance with the genius of the land
these were plural and arranged from
reinterpreting Vedanta where you say
that dualism is wrong and then you
practice dualism this is an old Shankar
Acharya itself supposed to have learnt
it from one of the pelea caste at that
time from there on right to the end
we'll have people simply running away
from Hinduism to Christianity and Islam
and so on with a lot of the other
varieties thrown in between various
combinations and so on and so forth
according to their own wherewithal and
the social capital they had and so on
now despite all these plurality and
diversity and multiplicity of atoms
there are some basic qualities common
across the land despite the fact that it
was not a coordinated effort expressive
of the existence situation of all these
communities the first of course is the
simultaneity of this both secular and
sacred
we always find it all over the across
the plane or across the subcontinent
every group tried to set up some similar
sacred canopies according to their own
efforts in political economy second
aspect was that they claimed all these
religious canopies they are constructing
were a continuity with
past continuity with their own past and
this is the genuine continuity not a new
fangled
you know what he called imitation of the
West or you know I mean British are
betting them to change over religion and
so on which was the Vivekananda's
comment on this they all claim that we
are a continuity with the with our own
ancient tradition and the third which is
the most important I will be working on
that is all these religious canopy is
very different and diversified they were
all the hair the core component was
embedding rational sociality rational
sociality within this very concept of
religion itself within the very concept
of religion itself any religion in
modern times if it is to be meaningful
or it is to be worth the name it has
should my should incorporate the
humanism an inclusive rational humanism
now it is this experience of vast number
of people thinking of themselves in
continuity and all the expressions
obviously were not even somewhere clear
some were not so clear somewhere you
know just having an idea somewhere
elaborate etcetera it is all this are
being summed up by Ambedkar forget
formulates it interprets it and offers
it to the public as his philosophy of
religion philosophy of religion
so it is the immediate ISA he calls his
predecessors as Buddha and others but
immediately he also had IOT dessert from
the south and Lakshman are so also I
wrote in English as his predecessors he
wrote two important books one as a
philosophy of Hinduism where he
deconstruct
and Buddha and Islam are ready
reconstructs it is both go together
without the deconstruction any
discussion on this reconstruction will
be only partial and eternal desert so
any any resistance movement unless it
has a reference point the contextual
situation of the dominance it is not you
know we will be only looking at belief
movement a reservation what are its
dynamics what are its deficiencies
etcetera etcetera but we will know how
it is being determined decided shaped
and sized by the dominance itself that
is the importance of the context now
before I get sort of this now going on
to this discussion you like to say that
if the Dalits are the generally Dalit
subalterns and so on lower caste what
they came to be called a lower caste
they did have a vision a coherent vision
of a total reality this is what I am
trying to make out they had a very
specific idea of what modernity means
what modernity means and it is not very
different from what the scholars in a
very high flaunting language and so on
they say all discussions of modernity
revolve around the rationality but then
it will be bureaucratic rationality
instrumental rationality metaphysical
rationality etcetera etcetera but a
Dalit and the solo subaltern groups will
find it as a social rationality ethical
rationality I would rather prefer
rational sociality now it is all the
other aspects of the modernity will fall
as consequences now the entire mass has
emerged as equal we need to have a
bureaucratic rationality etcetera
etcetera in order to technology and so
on it has to come out and serve the
basically social rationality now this
social rationality calls for a power
recon
structure some people who are having
privileges they lose their privileges
others try to get it is a power
relocation power relocation therefore it
will be contested and therefore there
will be ideology working against it and
so on and so forth now that the whole
core idea is that men look different men
and women look different on their
differences social qualities should be
constructed was the pre-modern insight
the new rationalized rational insight is
despite the fact men look different and
women look different they're short and
long and dark and gray and so on there
is a basic worth of human beings is the
same and it's on that social rationality
has to be built up this is this is the
basically the core idea second inside
this people brought in their own
articulations was much against the
colonial assertions and orientalist
assertions that India is not a singular
entity India is not an organically
developed to the society now that it is
a spiritual society India is a society
where there has been a conflict from the
beginning
multiple traditions over imposing on one
another and so on and finally this ask
materialist as in every years their own
strength is to unter trace what has been
called the sarimanok tradition sarimanok
tradition buddhism jainism and there is
a number of other things whose basic
insight was reality should not be taken
as it is given social reality the yeast
has to be changed into what ought to be
denied pre-constructed call upon to live
the human as it ought to be the
distinction between East and Art and the
struggle to reach the art as the ideal
is it and that has been embedded in
their discovery within cultures now more
specifically to religion when it comes
to the idea is is a religion does not
disappear
modernity secularization and so on but
what there is some amount of
secularization but basic processes that
religion requires democratization
everybody can read Bible directly and
interpret you don't need intermediaries
the authoritative dimension is being
done away with and that you are called
upon to embed the process of multiple
process of democratization within the
very heart of religion then the very
heart of religion if the if religion has
to be meaningful and and so address the
modern existence real problems
the fact is religion means deep
conviction moral conviction it's not
faith or you know we're tolerant
religions are editing we can believe in
and all it is a conviction
it's a conviction and the conviction
held sacred if the conviction is not
held sacred any amount of new changes in
the secular realm cannot be you know it
will never operate when your deep
conviction is in contrary to what is
formulated as constitutions etcetera and
so on it is not going to work if they on
this template I want to discuss actually
a little more but it can follow in the
thing the the present dilemma of the
Dalits about Genesis identity or
anonymity this I have been saying
now the valorisation of identity
indiscriminately setting it up higher
and then identity Trump's hierarchy
identity Trump's discrimination itself
all these are elite formulation of the
lid subaltern aspirations there is an
equal aspiration for anonymity as much
as for identity and very often identity
is taken up in order to reach anonymity
in order to reach anonymity that what
one should not control confuse
postmodernist identities
the Dalit aspirations to identity
certainly a lot of things can go on but
there's nothing except the last five oil
finishes they say in the construction of
my religion you have the very core the
Ambedkar constructed a particular
religion buddhist dhamma but if you see
the very core of that religion it
constitutes universality it constitutes
in your sanity the the particular least
articulation of dallas if you want to
interpret it insightfully not in a very
positive them see the utter menorah
called manifestos of political parties
and so on
if you intuitively interpret it they're
very particularity consists in
approximation and an aspiration to reach
universality so if someone wants to go
beyond that particularity in religion
for example buddha andes the buddha and
islam is nothing but except a rational
sociality explained and everybody
accepts before someone goes beyond that
with the seven sacred and other worship
etcetera it's their problem individuals
problem but the basic thing that the
demands is that these should embed
religious I mean rational sociality now
therefore it is not a pure question of
conversion from one religion to another
it is a demand for the conversion of all
religions into modernity at the same
time Ambedkar's challenge is just this
he did have a model but in the very
model if you internally look at the
model the demand is in for Kia logically
over relates the metanoia you convert
you don't have to go from Hinduism to
this one to that one and so on and so
forth you could he could if you want but
that's but that's not the basic demand
the basic demand is all religions will
have to recast themselves reconstitute
themselves in modernity encompassing and
embedding this what he called humanism
social rationality there was a lot of
cear implications of all this kind of
things but then you'll see it in a
course in our question discussion time
thank you very much
our next speaker is Raj Kumar Hans who
is currently a fellow at the Indian
Institute of Advanced Study in Simla and
reader in history at the MS University
of Baroda born to $1 he's born to a
dollop Christian family of Rolo Punjab
and in the late seventeen 1970s a
doctoral fellowship moved him from
Punjab to Gujarat where he began
research in the economic history of
South Gujarat in the 19th century Raj
Kumar Hans has been engaged in the
comparative study of Punjabi and
Gujarati cultures for the last 20 years
with a focus on the Dalit perspective in
recent years and I'm very grateful to
the Institute for inviting me to present
my findings and some perspective with
you this morning and I'm especially
thankful to joined for his persistence
to have me here you see from some
theoretical underpinnings now we move to
the empirical reality and religion has
been very central to the indian society
to the indian mind and i look into what
had been the status of caste and
untouchability among sexes because sikh
religion was a very powerful counter to
the Brahminical hierarchical solution
thinking in order
and I think what I will do is a longish
paper which I will try to our first-year
seed to give some offer some idea to
what the para Punjab landscape had been
Punjab as a frontier society as a
frontier society as a corridor to the
Indian subcontinent had always been in
flux it was in friendly being frontier
society it was never had is some kind of
she fixed ideas and social orders and so
on so and this landscape is also very as
the wide Plains unlike you see the
mountainous regions and so on and that
landscape had also made the mindscape of
Punjabis a Punjabi mindscape a very
independent of in in nature and nothing
could really have used something fixed
ideas and so on I will begin with as far
as Sikhism is concerned with one quote
from McAuliffe who was a very close
student of Sikhism and he this is in
1903 what he said about Hinduism and
Sikhism in that context he says truly
wonderful are the strength and vitality
of Hinduism
it is like the bore constrictor of the
Indian forests then if when a petty
enemy appears to worry it it riles
ronald's its opponent crush Asia crushes
it Henner's folds and finally causes it
to disappear in its capacious interior
Hinduism has embraced Sikhism inners
folds
the still comparatively young religion
is making a vigorous struggle for life
butters ultimate destruction is it has
apprehended inevitable without state
support notwithstanding the Sikh gurus
powerful denunciation of Brahmins
secular sects now rarely do anything
without their assistance so that is
around the close of the 19th century
what has happened to such a powerful
move in Punjab
what Bremen ISM could do to any Garrett
Arian powerful social movement so I will
now go back to the context of Sikhism
the context in which Sikhism arose as a
new religion and I think that context
for the subcontinent is very very
important because moving moving away
from the Eurocentric readings of the
past if we we can really think of the
Indian Rana sir in a very different way
because what was happening in the 14th
century of 15th century there was
powerful current of liberation and
thoughts and we had Sufi Saints where
Bogut's were trying to have you see the
egalitarian thoughts all together and
this is the context in which Sikhism
also strike you see roots in Punjab now
this is the context which could be seen
as the Indian Renison where all these
Sufi Saints and sons who are trying to
counter you see provide a counter
culture in terms of not only thought but
also the social ordering no it also
anyway can be seen as the beginning of
the modernity
too often modernity is linked up again
in Eurocentric way only seen in the
either in the late 18th century or in
the 19th century but where these kind of
librational thoughts one can see that
there was you see modernity Indian
modernity taking striking roots in the
subcontinent so ideas and philosophy of
liberation of Sikhism is is also very
inclusive because I think as the only
Guru Granth Sahib which was canonized in
1604 but as the only perhaps the only
sacred text in the entire world which is
very inclusive because it doesn't only
contain the you see the thoughts off and
Sikh gurus sip 5 SEC rules but also at
26 other you see Sufis and saints and
this is what also makes it what loc s
was pointing out that is secular and
sacred there was almost in meshing of
the two that it was creating a space
guru nanak who was a great traveler he
was gathering you see all these thoughts
from all over not only india but also
going abroad and he was in makkah and so
on so this context of you see this
opening up of a very different i'm new
thoughts around the liberation and
democratic orders who there's very
important for and i've gone through most
the guru granth i've and the original
text in punjabi and what we find is that
the way it was democratization of
society was being
you see attempts were being made by the
gurus and it's not only at the level of
thought but in practice what they said
guru was trying to do these the ideas of
Sangha panget and Lunger where people
belonging to different caste and
communities could sit together they were
eat together and so on and so much so
that even the distinction between the
guru and disciples were being sore done
away with so this complete
democratization of the society was being
used to try it out and the deformation
of where the formation of culture with
the tenth guru the distinction between
the Guru and the disciple was also
completely being merged so there is a
that concept of RP Gor Jayla so so guru
also became becomes Jayla as known this
really empowered the society in such a
way that you see there was the caste ISM
cart even if the cost could not be done
away with what casteist attitude that
had come to really be destroyed by the
Sikh gurus and moreover you see this is
very very that's exemplified and won a
large number of the lists got integrated
into the Sikh movement in the 16th
century itself and it's exemplified by
one of the Dalit Dalit family I'm
talking of hi Jetta who was who belong
to the Dalit friendly and he was the
person responsible who had carried this
weird head of nine ninth guru from
Billie Tsien reach out to
a nun course I have and he was the one
whose family had been part of a Sikh
movement for nearly five generations and
his father Sutherland was a accomplished
musician and one who was living in Delhi
and one of the daughter of another
accomplished Brahman marry magician had
fallen in love with southern on and and
on her insistence of this daughter
larvan T you see the Brahmins that had
agreed to give his daughter to him but
there was uproar among the Brahmans this
Brahmin family belonged to a nigga and
once the Guru came to know it Saarinen
became very close to Guru Thea father
and guru nanak guru they - bahasa
finally if he got him married convinced
be brahmin and and then this family had
been all along you see very close to the
Guru family and his another son this was
my data I was the first son of sadhana
and another son was born in Patna while
the Guru was on his into interest who
saw him and so on know what I'm trying
to say by the way bringing of this
family is that he once he had brought
this weird head of the guru Tegh Bahadur
to guru Govind Singh he was embraced by
Guru Gobind Singh and that said that run
great a guru K abate a that Dennis are
the true sons of the gurus and so much
so that around with he was also they are
now pronounced as the fifth son of the
Guru himself guru had four sons and he
was
declared as the fifths I have gather
know and now this such a large number of
you see that it said joined the Sikh
religion that during band avocadoes
after Guru Guru Gobind Singh's death
never had was dispatched to Punjab and
it was the large number of Dalits who
had become the giant the armies of banda
baja de and i have used some of the
persian sources that how it was for
nearly seven years there was rule off
you see lower caste and Dalits in punjab
so it's not only in the first half of
the 18th century but throughout the 18th
century there was another you see when
there was persecution by the Mughals and
they were at several attacks by amateurs
early in sex in the in Punjab in the
18th century one when the 6re conversed
from these in the mid nineteen
eighteenth century they were one of the
they were divided into five separate
fighting guns and one of the adults was
purely constituted of for the that it's
and so much so that you see the cast
distinctions had come to some what you
see abolished among six that the rise of
the juts who were also who who were the
shooters of the earlier times
they also emerged as powerful asked
community in the 18th century and once
that was happening they they they tried
to eliminate you see Dalit the rise of
the Denison beat singer and Greta and
they got him killed in eighteen
1761 or so and so much so that the
dollars came to be integrated into the
sacred religion in such a way that in
Congress are the Golden Temple there
were several kind of rest places called
bangles and one of the rest pieces was
also constructed by the Dalits within
the golden temple complex in 1826 it is
it'll only after the establishment of
the British the the Renji sings rule by
the set power that the cost ism again
came to be introduced by the large
number of Brahmins who had joined not
only the order of six but also the
armies of you know the administration of
Renji Singh so this this had by the
close of the 19th century the idols
idols had also been introduced into the
golden temple complex and almost the
mahants came to control the all the guru
Aras the Brahmin were hands and at the
resurgence of the revival of the Sikh
militancy that is sinks of a movement
and the even there you see the marble
Saints yeah the Dulles played a very
very central role in the revival of the
fundamentals of sake Sikhism where their
eligibility was questioned and the cost
ISM to be encountered even in the the
pillar of the saint sava movement was
also Dalit Johnny Depp Singh and
thereafter the sex had to launch very
long struggle of liberation of Gurdwara
is from the control of the Brahmin
Mahan's
and that had continued to be
the story tell the mid twentieth century
and it's not only that the
untouchability and caste which had been
done away with for the first 300 years
of Sikh religion it came to be
reintroduced and it came to afflict the
body politic of six in by the end of the
19th century in such a way that there
there was this danger that was expressed
by not only by the in external kind of
observers like McAuliffe and other
people but also internally it was felt
and even questioned Singh came to
observe it in the by the mid twentieth
century that if such a in such a way if
Sikhism continued to be brahmin eyes
there is a danger that by the end of the
20th century successor would altogether
be that will be overusing and I end my
you see this thought with the one of the
no there is a so much questioning by the
Dalit intellectuals that I was talking
to one of the Dalit intellectuals who
had written history of the the lists of
six I I was talking to him that what is
this future of sexism and what is the
future of Dalits in Sikhism and he was
saying that sit there's only the that is
who can save you see the Sikh religion
from extinction because they had been
the most loyal followers of the sixth
and they had
got the citizens it's political rule in
the 18th century and while you see they
had been made to made to they if the
Dalit said that you see not been loyal
to Sikhism they they would it would have
been very very different kind of story
for the sake of the macaque so I think I
will stop this it would have been better
if I were reading but I think I've lost
third speaker is Nate Roberts who is a
PhD in anthropology from from Columbia
and he is now a visiting scholar in the
Department of South Asia studies at the
University of Pennsylvania he has been
working with Dalit slum dwellers in
urban South India and his research has
focused on an ongoing conversion
movement in which roughly half the slums
women have become Pentecostal Christians
his current project reproaches the topic
of conversion in India this time
focusing on the national elite by
examining the political and theoretical
stakes in efforts by Hindu majoritarian
to outlaw religious conversion
especially conversions by dulles women
who seek to leave Hinduism for Islam or
Christianity thank you
the title of this paper is Pentecostal
conversion and Dalit utopia historically
in the articulation of the LAT
consciousness there is a tension between
valid identity and cashless identity I'm
reading from the prompt given to
panelists to which I'm responding how
does the Dalit project can of conversion
out of Brahminical traditions articulate
with the project of reconstructing an
indigenous past I want to pause on that
word indigenous because I will come back
okay so historically there has been
attention between the late identity and
cast less identity because a paramount
goal among those who describe themselves
as dull it has been the ultimate
eradication of the structures political
economic as well as cultural that served
to set them apart and yet in organizing
around this name it is alleged that they
are in fact continuing to set themselves
apart from others although this of
course depends on how the lit is defined
and how the term is used in practice
however the risk that theirs will become
yet another identitarian movement
jostling for position policing its own
members and seeking to advance their
interests against others is a real one
and one moreover that is well recognized
by the intellectuals in describing this
as a risk I do not mean to imply any
kind of value judgment one could argue
that for Dalits to establish themselves
as a permanent interest group in the
indian scene makes a lot of sense
politically and that there's nothing
inherently wrong with an historically
dominated sub population opting for such
an approach such a state of affairs is a
risk only in relation to the utopian
goal in which all vestiges of caste
discrimination are eradicated this
utopianism is most famously associated
with dr. BR Ambedkar for whom a
mobilization around the Dalit identity
was a necessary but temporary strategy
the final goal of which was the
dissolution of the category another
bullet after all is not an ethnic
identity to be celebrated but an
affliction to be overcome similarly
utopian understanding of the term Dalit
can be found in the writings of many
contemporary theorists of the Dalit
question two of whom because they're
with us here today I will focus on the
first is Gopal guru who envisions Dalit
as comprising not only caste but also
quote class and gender dimensions and
furthermore as being fundamentally
distinct from the categories of state
patronage such as SC or of electoral
politics such as majority and minority
as posited by quote certain Bahujan
leaders what that in fact means apart
from its negative relation to the
designations be they those of the state
or reformists like Gandhi is according
to guru assent
- the unfixed and not opposed to such
categories as subaltern Bahujan Buddhist
or proletarian the second thinker I will
mention gained an eye out today
similarly described the eyes Asian as
incorporating gender parity dignity of
labour horizontal division of labour
heterodox interpretation of socio
religious values and so on and
furthermore denies that Dalit is quote a
category of exclusivism sectarianism
marked by a vindictiveness against caste
Hindus to see phthalates in exclusivist
terms is simply a misunderstanding
according to Quran then a false image he
attributed primarily to the paranoia of
caste Hindus and other privileged groups
although he admits that such an image is
shared by some pilots as well
what Gajendra and gopu gopal guru are
describing as submit is not an identity
at all but a transformative project and
one that is engaging Dan's words
Liberatore not merely of self but of
other as well instead of ink accepting
iron curtain' gajanan continues the
concept of darkness quote calls for
caste Hindus to shed their inhumane
existence and assume subject positions
within the humane values of the
marginalized cultures therefore any
sectarian organisation of Dalit
Mahajan's is antithetical to the very
principle of this category rather it
provides a chance for the aggressors to
redeem themselves it provides a chance
for the aggressors to redeem themselves
I find this phrase and in particular the
use of the term redemption highly
significant but before proceeding to my
own argument I would like to point out
one small gap in gauge engines account
as well as in Bhopal gurus bones show a
tendency to identify the other of Dalit
as the caste Hindoo but if Dalit really
is to incorporate plural forms of sub
alternate II including gender the
aggressors
whom Dalit calls upon to redeem
themselves cannot be just caste Hindus
but must include exporters of all
stripes landowners imperialists
moneylenders and dowdy takers to name
just a few
of equal significance it must include
caste Christians in South India where my
own research is focused caste divisions
are no less significant
among Christians than among Hindus my
research assistant was a Dalit from a
village in which all the Dalits were
Roman Catholic and so too were all
members of the dominant caste who beat
and exploited them prevented them from
acquiring land forbade their funeral
possessions from using public roads and
so on all multicast denominations of
Christianity moreover are dominated by
caste Christians who know less than
their Hindi counterparts actively
favored their own caste folk and seek to
exclude the le'ts from any form of into
institutional benefits whenever possible
by treating caste as an essentially
Hindu problem and that only accidentally
obtains among non Hindus moreover we are
unwittingly reproducing the logic of the
state the codes caste as Hindu by
excluding Christian and Muslim Dalits
from the list of Scheduled Castes as
well as the logic of hindu reformists
like gandhi who for historical reasons
historically related reasons insisted
that caste was a problem of hindus and
hindus alone but it is beyond the scope
of my paper to dwell on any further on
this aporia instead what I would like to
consider is how widespread the notion of
the utopian vision gajender Anand Gopal
guru attribute to the term Dalit in fact
is and I'll argue that the atop
utopianism they articulate is not at all
confined to select few theorists but as
my own ethnographic research in the
Dulwich slum in northern Chennai reveals
is emphatically embraced by ordinary
impoverished and often wholly unlettered
Dalits as well most of whom have little
or no actual knowledge of invaders
thoughts thought and do not ordinarily
use the term dull it
these slum dwellers do not however
reject the term Dalit as do many
middle-class Dalits who according to
guru view it as quote regressive
derogatory and hence undesirable rather
it is simply that it remains for them a
foreign loan word and not part of their
daily usage the term most caught they
most commonly used to describe
themselves especially when
distinguishing themselves from the
dominant caste society is simply the
poor ela
non slum dwellers are cast people for
the two are substantially one in the
same
Safari slum dwellers are concerned are
referred to as the privileged viseu de
Ivanka or the rich pannacotta when used
in the sense the poor and the privileged
refer not to scale our positions which
is social relation between opposed
categories of persons there is no
sliding scale between poverty and
privileged the poor are poor because of
the rich specifically they are poor
because the rich monopolize resources
resources economic political and
symbolic at the expense of and to the
exclusion of the poor and justify their
actions by claiming falsely that the
poor are inherently unworthy in this way
the discourse of the slum encompasses
both what we refer to as class and caste
it also encompasses the unequal gendered
relations between men and women for
within the slum women as a class are
said to be poor in rule 8 as or the poor
in relation to men slum dwellers make no
attempt to justify this inequality both
men and women's subscribe in principle
to new Galit aryan gender ideology it is
just that their ideals in this case more
often than not are honored in the breach
one arena in which these understandings
are most clearly articulated is in the
discourse of slum Pentecostal churches
the 30 are more small locally based and
locally led Pentecostal congregations
that have sprung up in vyasa party a
large industrial slum in northern
chennai over the past two decades in
what follows i will provide examples
extracted from Pentecostal sermons my
purpose is to read them systematically
for the aspirations they encode i am not
in other words recommending
Pentecostalism as a viable program of
social or political advancement for slum
dwellers the same time i can think of no
reason to oppose it that does not
implicitly draw on indigenous narratives
in the first extract I will read please
notice that poor does not signify merely
lacking in money but also degraded in
the
having been degraded by others of equal
significance is the transvaluation of
values the pastor performs by which what
is wrongfully treated as worthless is
revealed in fact to be of great value
quote he lifts the poor from the dusty
garbage and raises them from their
misery who are the poor he is raising
from the dust what do we call garbage
what is of no use is garbage but now did
you see it on television from waste they
have made electricity did you know that
from garbage they're going to produce
electricity that which they deem useless
unwanted rotten they are using this
waste today in the name of Christ for
electricity the villagers and the term
uses is grommeted a term which refers
specifically to the residents of the
caste village the ore as opposed to the
Dalit hamlet or cherry the Gromit are
everybody they will know today they are
saying he's not useful for anything
instead of living here he should go
elsewhere they say you are a shameful
man your life is worthless you earn
nothing for your family you have not a
single paisa what are you living for die
assuming you to be dirt they throw you
away but to you Jesus says give me your
voice your suffering your heart to me I
will make you invaluable I will make you
respected those who said you're a
disgrace Kress will disgrace them in
this way the discourse of slum
Pentecostal Christianity mirrors and
amplifies the pervading discourse of the
slum as a whole as in the latter what is
at issue is not just symbolic
degradation being treated like dirt or
even just spatial segregation being
forced literally to live apart in a
dumping ground but economic
subordination the revolution slum
Pentecostals envision is also of an
entirely worldly sort thus in another
past passage the pastor explains God's
programmed thus quote he wants to create
a human court that is why he made God in
man's man in God's image but how does
this emphasis on retribution compare
with the agenda Anne's argument
that the concept Dalit does not involve
any vindictiveness towards caste Hindus
in two ways I argue that despite its
longing for worldly justice and
punishment of the aggressors the
discourse of slum Pentecostalism is not
a vindictive one with respect to caste
Hindus first those who will be punished
are not caste Hindus but caste people
and even then from contacts is clear
that what is condemned is not the fact
they happened to be born into caste
society but the act of maintaining and
reproducing caste privilege by degrading
others and making them poor nor do pada
Pentecostals ever say that Hindus as
sucks will be punished according to the
Pentecostals of the slum worshipping
Hindu god is not a sin but merely an
error in that they are totally
ineffective Hindu gods themselves are
not figured as evil or diabolical beings
who encourage inhuman practices but mere
nonentities secondly salvation the
salvation that slum Pentecostal sikh is
open to everyone not just the poor in
the oppressed and moreover according to
them because moreover according to them
everyone actually needs salvation it is
just that those with worldly pros rip
worldly privileges based on the
suffering of others typically failed to
realize this fact and to be saved the
privileged need only ceased to lord over
others thus just as with the category of
Dalit which contains and argues calls
upon the dominant to shed their inhumane
existence and provides a chance for the
aggressors to redeem themselves so too
with slum Pentecostalism thus far I've
discussed how salaam Pentecostalism
speaks of to slum dwellers as caste in
class subjects what is perhaps more
prominent in the discourse of the slum
church is the extent to which it
addresses gendered forms of suffering
and it is no accident that upwards of
90% of Pentecostals in the slum are
women this may come as a surprise to
those who on the basis of North American
experience associate Pentecostalism with
patriarchal gender norms consider next
the surprising gloss one pastor put on
the Adam story of Adam and Eve in a
sermon addressed primarily to the men of
his congregation
what did Eve do she called to him Adam
Adam
this fruit it's very sweet it's
wonderful my eyes were opened you should
try it too
she said this and gave the fruit to Adam
Adam tasted it why because for Adam mrs.
Adams words were very sweet he ate it
and his eyes were opened hallelujah to
listen to one's wife's words is
important the man should think and come
to his own conclusions but only after
listening to his wife a wife is not a
slave you must listen to her if you keep
shaking your head to everything she says
we will all be ruined in the world where
women are normally held responsible for
household tasks and judged harshly for
any shortcoming in this domain another
pastor addressed women the women of his
congregation thus quote those of you who
are attracted by the Holy Spirit you
will be saved and when you are saved you
will no longer be trapped by matters of
the family you will not be overly
concerned with looking after your
children about your household tasks you
will say I don't care there's no need
for that
flatly contravening received norms in
which a woman's worth is tied up with
her role as an auspicious Court in court
house keeper of the household in other
words Pentecostal women are presented
with a vision of salvation in which the
household doesn't even figure about your
household tasks you will say I don't
care these are shocking and even
revolutionary words another aspect of
auspiciousness is the emphasis it places
on woman's physical beauty and
ornamentation this too is attacked by
slum Pentecostalism the revolution
against beauty however is not envisioned
as something new but as a return to the
past an ancient path quote unquote
that is simultaneously the only livable
future quote clap your hands hallelujah
we must look to the good path and walk
the good way we must stand on this
ancient path you need not use outward
aids to make yourself beautiful such as
the way you do your hair or jewelry you
put on or the dresses you wear for your
beauty is your true inner self the
ageless beauty of a gentle and quiet
spirit which is the greatest value in
God's sight what is indestructible
beauty knowing the ancient path and
following it that is in destructor
Beauty or as one Pentecostalism woman
cried out in the middle of church jesus
is with me i am different i am in
everything or father i am myself i am
myself i am different
i am myself the ancient path is figured
as an indigenous one in that it
represents the true nature and authentic
past of Dalits and yet does not partake
of a national imaginary in which
indigenous is categorical 'i opposed to
foreign thus in illustrating what the
ancient path entailed the pastor quoted
above procedures described it as
encompassing the modern west positing me
an american anthropologist as an
exemplar the ancient path what is it
look at robert sitting here do you know
what he and his family do i asked him
what the husband wife do in new york
america and he told me what they do is
they cook together the chore of cooking
the husband and wife do it together
and then i asked him what they cook do
you know what he told me beef the fact
that of all the foods i had told the
pastor we cook in my house the one he
chose to highlight to his congregation
was beef is by no means accidental in
doing so the pastor wove together the
ancient the quintessential adalat and
what is in fact most modern and
egalitarian is being all of a piece this
is a common feature of slum Pentecostal
discourse as i mentioned above the
designation the poor refers not just to
caste and class subjects but also to
slum women in relation to slum men the
semantic ambiguities are these semantic
ambiguities are used to COO to great
effect by slum pastors and a great many
times the salvation promised in slum
sermons is phrased in ways that rendered
the distinctions among caste class and
gender suffering meaningless a speech
that begins by clearly referring to slum
dwellers collective suffering in
relation to the non slum or caste
society often morphs imperceptibly into
a tirade against the suffering of slum
women in relation to slum men and back
again such that one is left with the
impression that they all are just
different aspects of a larger totality
known as sin now in
interpreting some Pentecostalism
discourse this way I'm treating the
Dalits of Islam as dullard intellectuals
and what I'm saying here is that the
fact they use a single term for for to
encompass both passed and class it's not
a I called it a semantic ambiguity but
actually I think it's a theoretically
productive move so in medieval European
philosophy there's something called
distinction between distinct your reales
and distinct Co Rossi and dotty annales
distinctly Alice is a distinction that
exists in reality say between a bronze
sphere and a marble cube there are two
different things whereas the distinction
between this cube itself being brahms
and at being a sphere sorry this bronze
fear being bronze and it being a sphere
that the distinction that exists within
rationality what the Scholastic's didn't
say or didn't add is that rationality is
not singular there are multiple
rationalities so the rationality which
describes the same person as adalat or a
cast subject and as a class subject is a
distinction of rationality with a
particular valence and the fact to a one
that by necessarily draws upon you no
stock tropes of the poor Brahmin you
know so in order to say they're all
support or the rich dullard but but of
course not all one minute it'll be less
than one minute
not all rationalities are the same not
all rationalities work to the same
effect
and so my my suggestion is that that in
fact the discourse they used to describe
themselves as poor which is encompassing
these things isn't just conflating
distinctions which are real it is
refusing distinctions which are made by
a particular rationality in favor of a
separateness or an identity that is real
between Dalits as caste subjects and his
class subjects thank you
our last speaker is Massoud Allen
Falacci who who is like an assistant
professor of Islamic Studies at Maulana
Azad national Aalto University he's
published numerous articles and research
papers and his book which has gone into
its second edition is called Muslims and
caste ISM in India he he is currently
finishing his second book on the reality
of caste in marriage in the Muslim world
and so our doctor thanks this artisan
really thanks to saltation Department to
organize this kind of contents and a lot
of things brother vol 2 bringing me and
Sabina madam confirming Lee all
information about the infants my paper
have three aspects is the strength of
Sharia literature an Arabic language I
will discuss about the what is the
position of course in Islam secondly
what is the historical background and
and in a present time what is the fact
and what is a three step of cast among
Muslims as I read many books on custom
of Muslims will by siliceous and aunt
ferjeen's there they have a study about
society but really someone raised a
question about the cost among Islam's
and about writings of Alma's in Islamic
scholars the first of all we have to
know what is the reality in Islam
what is the first reality as Quran and
professor edition we know that in Islam
no distinction between one cost another
caused the chronic were says Allah says
in one verse in surah hujrat over the
people I created you from my mine and
male a female and made you in people and
tribes that you know and other and among
you the best is one who is doing good
deals the last sermon after sermon
purpose Mohammed said his no superiority
of Arab on non Arabs no squatty of none
of our Arab no spiotti of black and
white no security of will avoid on Blake
all people are from Adam and other was
get rid from play the things that this
kind of thing in Islam the how kanka
system came in with society as you know
our pre Islamic history that Arab
society have a social stratification or
have considered himself I am Unger of
grass considered himself so much high
higher than others but after Islam all
things made as harm but we know the
Quran says the founder of car system and
cost way this commission is Satan who is
the Arabic name and chronic name is
Elise when other allocated Adam and
ordered angels and winds to bow down in
front of other just for respect all of
they've done except second Allah asked
why didn't do the Quranic verse said the
argue the satan argued colophony mean
our o'clock you mean team you created me
from fire and you created him from clay
the nature of fire is good to up
initiative kelly go to down how can a
high question people can go down in
front of no people the islamic Quranic
teachings that I found refer first ISM
and custom
second after prophet muhammad peace be
upon him and till the second second
caliph or mother I didn't see any cost
among Muslim colleges commission but in
third Kali's period third caliph is
Usman one person name is Abdullah and
Sabah converted in Islam and he started
caste-based discrimination and the
present after every after is tilde when
islam came after that the among Muslim
still believe me Saba is the founder of
car system and his thought is spirited
young like will fire and people came
from Iran and kilos of man and they said
that Ali is the cousin for prophet and
he belongs with the goal of Hashem so he
is more deserving than with one to be a
caliph and after many periods we see the
cost basis Commission among Arabs and
non-arabs still became more stronger in
Omaha sphere we can see there is a group
in Iran name is Sharia who compared
themselves that they are greater than
Islamic teachings and others and in
reflect of these things are also I have
description with them Hodgman use of the
most famous governor of Iraq ordered in
Kufa that no non of can we uh can we
later a prayer in a buzzy period a
persecutor have root the solution of a
superior routine caste-based
discrimination because Abbasid period
I'm just using the Arabic precision
although most references my my paper
Arabic Persian and Odin so I whatever I
reference from these books only the
upper superior have root of in-car
system a Muslim cross on e who was the
most company of this
caliphate he started the security offer
Annabeth Allah birth means
in Indian Khan's contesters science kiss
a failure these the higher is the other
batteries of ammonia Prophet Mohammed so
they should be we caliph and we can see
that after that the bossy bossy rulers
came and the same period they're
fighting between Abbasid and fat mites
means the Annabeth
they are veneno via Sophia mm no we are
superior and we just bought the Indian
context how the in India caste system
started till nine nine hundred ninety
five the error rule was in unseen who
didn't find any cars which transmission
in our Arabic and O two literature that
we had to have this kind of things but
even Mohammed owari
Ghaznavi could be never these fears are
we didn't find and these people could
have been as I work so she's been could
within a buck to move on the warrior and
Goswami they made their slaves the
governor I mean I could be I was married
his daughter with some students
estimation who does fillet offer to do
the network but the custom of our
Muslims in India I started by shooting
in so to me we just live not Salil slave
of slave means could be never was slave
of human body and in substance level
could be never
from here we can find a historically a
lot of examples of cost estimation
should the insert image not involve all
have a inquiry about the cost are for
his officials and he dismissed
one-time 3033 low-cost Muslims from his
kingdom how the low-cost people can be
governor and any on any position even he
has bent over one he used to say when I
see
any low-cost my blood used to why we can
find these examples in the Bernie book
30 keepers shiny now after that the
Iranian planes among India Muslims are
so much so we can see the many books in
Iran written by light light penis with
beam to see a flock a nursery a second
book the Johnny Murphy be the third
criterion nizam al-mulk in his talk nama
he told the caste system should be like
peer islam and because of these things
we can find in till now in Iran there is
the seeing example that it is a serious
family their turban is blank and non
serious trouble is righty and other
color Nancy you cannot wear a black
turban and this is not only in Iran in
Egypt also in India also we can see
after we can see many examples in the
Mughal period and subtle period in flow
chateau la cleared ke cost based
discussion among Muslims on high
position and even aquifer is a call
so most secular among Indian historians
and I think in general the world
historians he ordered the his or in
Persian or than in we can find this
without any book Montefiore he said
Allah as hardness in him darshan Amana
and he facade Kamiya earth for me hazard
with the so-called low caste people
should not allow to get education
because because these their education
the facade corruption is born that
occurs between and he one time once a
year I reveal against aqua but he didn't
allow to kill him because he say it you
can see the sikandar lodi period ascetic
well he was
accuse because he helped some still some
government money but when he brought her
in front of the second LOD he and not he
given pardon he told okay you can take
these through these money also because
you say it and after this historical
events become that unsaved and we shall
suffer he these are also till now
palaces the first the last Mughal
Emperor for the so much trouble but
still he used to say in our army should
be only say yeah shake but Hank asks who
upper caste no loca lower castes are
insane is not different from others
he's the consider most religious person
among Muslim scholars in India and in
era also as I know about little
literature but he also did cos which is
commissioned in his period one fatwa
books the Vltava India compiled in this
book curve we can find many caste based
discrimination among Muslims and he said
discussed law discussed hi after that if
he have to come about Muslim scholars
what is the Muslim scholars views about
the caste drama Muslims in general we
can find that from Sultana period till
till now the Muslim scholars
supported cautious among Muslims in the
period of Muhammad Allah and Allah the
quote in historian of their both pairs
Bernie he wrote aa Futaba jihad re and
his book also the very pure shy you can
see a fine many cosmetician writings and
what was means the rule shocking
schipper he told no lower caste could be
allowed to get education and if a
teacher can do he should be punished the
other he also said
giving a given to give education low
caste people is like to put Nicholas off
Paul and world internet of soy and dog
and he just not his thought he I think
from Quran and to these first editions
but we never find this kind of teaching
in Islam Islam is totally against of
this teaching this long said terrible
ill me for is eternal awfully mean
called a Muslim University
makini education is compulsory for all
Muslims mean and female we have to come
in the period of October this is the one
person name is very famous person until
now is the also sufi name is jihad jihad
occurs there on sale to be in Jihad on
and girls heels same ideas even he told
that prophet said we cannot eat ten with
ten people's like Barbra washerman and
others and he argue from Hadees but not
any teach in Islam in the period of last
save one person born name is Charlotte
lav he's the most respected person from
all Muslim sects but then he also have
cost with and fought was now in
contemporary India become the four major
groups in India like Brandis a ladies
they won DS and
jamaat-e-islami an among team Allah DS
and which is calling / javi in English
term and jamaat-e-islami the consider
moves secular I'm not arguing
they have you are used K we are doing
rationalize their we have rational
people but in their all founders like
Muhammadu be the most plumbing founder
and you can go to the ladies fonder
resolution de la vie
they all have
dessert was and they have given a
football if sayeth caste girl marry with
non-si advice this kind of marry will
not be very it is a valley automatically
no need to break in court and anywhere
but much autonomy the most restrictive
person in the one he said yes sir well
say yes can marry within non say yen but
other cannot marry but if he marry a non
see a girl and a child born his status
is not like the Saiga the witness again
like him honest with his saying I mean
can marry with the other girl but
especially in lower than what she will
say your boy and the most important
thing there to say that Mahon the father
of Muslim Egyptian India he is not
different others he used to abuse lower
caste Muslims
he said that nine 1857 revolt is not by
others only we worse and lower caste
people and we can come to this vision
the little Muslims struggle we never
find that any moment launched during a
fifty and sixty before in Britain to
India and now I will cry I'm sorry his
moment is not like all OBC the lips and
Muslims Muslims just for one cost me
worse is called women and jalaja all do
an Arabic language but in in current
contemporary India the three and four
groups doing a working on this way one
is our India back on boosting moisture
namely changed now on India Muslim
merger and second is all India posada
Muslim Maha's and thirties Akhil
Maharashtra critics emerge 40s India
Indian welcome us device but above both
of them missed the route and join with
political parties
and both others are doing for the
treatment of the lit Muslims and I hope
they will it is their goal thanks a lot
which listening
you